en france l'association france était
pédiatre a commencé à dire qu'il était
plus contaminés donc peu contaminants et
puis à la finalement le contraire a été
a été mon prêt puisque en angleterre il
a bien été dit que là le taux de portage
des enfants à partir du nizan données de
10 à 15 ans étaient à peu près le même
que celui des adultes
il ya peu près trois semaines mais ça
donc ils sont beaucoup moins malade sa
c'est sûr à 100% mais ils sont pas plus
mais ils sont prisonniers
autant contaminants que des jeunes des
jeunes adolescents ou des jeunes baby et
sont plus souvent asymptomatique mais
peuvent transmettre
d'où d'ailleurs les premières mesures
qu'elle était lasse au niveau des écoles
là on s'appuyait sur d'autres maladies
virales finalement sans compte que ben
c'est la même chose pour si on veut
bloquer la dissémination soit en fait à
déconfinement terrible et finalement
inacceptable
soit on vaccine très largement celle ci
commence à se faire dans des pays comme
israël
alors sachons que le vaccin fighter a
été autorisé pour des gens de plus de 16
ans mais il ya des apparemment des des
expérimentations chez des grands enfants
qui sont ils sont en cours
personnellement je pense qu'il faudrait
probablement vacciner des grands enfants
en paix parce qu'ils sont à partir du
collège ça me paraît évident voire voir
à moins que le collège
moi je suis un homme les adolescents je
pense que c'est une population qui
envahira besoin qui a quand même des cas
critiques important pour les enfants
j'ai plus on va bienvenu en ces termes
on me vacciner les enfants défavorisés
du mans qu'il ya un bénéfice risque et
la question qui reste c'est aussi
comment ce vaccin va limiter la
transmission en france la bonne nouvelle
c'est que si le variant 10 anglais en
train de devenir majoritaires dans notre
pays ça dépend des régions mais par
exemple nous on a séquencé et dans
l'autre france celle hors de 60 à 65%
ce variant ni ne modifie pas la réponse
immunitaire après vaccination
et quant aux variants sud africain il
est extrêmement minoritaire sur le
territoire français
les variantes telles qu'ils sont ne sont
pas un obstacle à la vaccination qu'il
faut développer le plus vite possible
parce que plus on aura de personnes
vaccinées plus on diminue la
dissémination du virus et plus on
diminue le risque d'apparition d'un
variant de roubaix de de tarbes de paris
qui puisse être résistant à la
vaccination en israël il ya eu des
premières études sur la transmissibilité
du virus chez des gens qui ont déjà été
vaccinées il ya au moins une étude qui a
été présenté qui semble montrer comme on
pouvait s'y attendre d'ailleurs que les
gens vaccinés ne transmette ni à la
maladie très la question maintenant
c'est tous les pays où il n'ya pas de
mexes nation ou très peu qui peuvent
rester un vivier le développement de
nouveaux variants et d'où l'importance
de vacciner au plus vite l'ensemble des
pays du monde
après il ya une autre cinétique il est
en cours c'est la fairy tail vont
apparaître les variants et notamment de
nouveaux variants mon frère est chose à
dire par là dessus il pourrait échapper
au 25
donc après à la capacité à produire même
si
on sait que l'aca et rennes sont
relativement faciles à a développé par
rapport à nouveau l'arrière il faudra
quand même un certain temps donc on va
voir un peu et course et on s'est pendu
quelle va être la seule équipe exact